[Music]
on this wednesday night
haiti's president assassinated at home
jovanelle moise attacked in the middle
of the night while he slept
there's been a lot of problems but then
again we never expected this
what neighbors saw and heard plus the
intensifying political crisis gripping
one of the world's poorest countries
a new covet-19 variant arrives in canada
viruses are always evolving what's known
about lambda and how well vaccines work
against it
working full-time but only four days a
week
the challenges and perks
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser good evening and thank you
for joining us
we begin tonight with the assassination
of a world leader
and a country on edge the president of
haiti giovannelle moyes
is dead gunman stormed his home in
port-au-prince in the middle of the
night
who orchestrated the attack and why
remains unknown
though he had his share of enemies the
53-year-old became president in 2017
after winning a disputed election that
saw one of the lowest turnouts in the
country's history
he dissolved parliament more than a year
ago and began ruling by decree
under his leadership haiti the poorest
country in the americas
plunged further into economic crisis and
has been plagued by corruption
allegations
and gang violence protesters have been
calling for moise to go for months
earlier this year he claimed he thwarted
an attempted coup
and a plot to murder him haiti is under
siege tonight the international airport
is closed so is the land border with the
dominican republic
canadian citizens in the country are
advised to limit their movements
prime minister justin trudeau seen here
with moise at the g7 summit in quebec
three years ago
called the killing appalling caught in
the turmoil though are the millions of
people
in that country that have faced crisis
after crisis
mike armstrong has our top story tonight
it was in the hilly suburbs of paro pres
at his home
that the haitian president was
assassinated armed gunmen attacking just
after 1am wednesday
leaving behind bullet holes ski masks
and a growing political crisis
these are videos posted by a haitian
media outlet it says they were filmed
during the attack according to witnesses
quoted in local media the gunmen were
yelling
claiming to be with the u.s drug
enforcement agency
some also report hearing drones overhead
and a grenade explode
this man says he heard a boom and felt
the ground shake
in a statement to the nation the interim
prime minister says the attackers spoke
english and spanish claude josef called
it a highly coordinated attack
by a highly trained group it was the
interim prime minister who confirmed
president jovenel moyes had been killed
and his wife the first lady shot and
wounded joseph has declared a state of
emergency
and is calling for calm calm
is not something haitians have seen much
of in recent years
on top of the tumultuous political
situation they're having to deal with a
kidnapping crisis
and a failing economy
add to that a capital gripped by gang
violence
armed groups and police have battled in
the streets for months
with civilians caught in the middle east
at montreal's haitian radio station the
news director says the situation is so
bad in the capital
tens of thousands have fled in recent
months
emanuel pierre says the main entrances
to poro price from the south and the
north
are both controlled by gangs for
canada's haitian community
something had to give tensions were too
high but most expected moyes to flee the
country
not be killed it couldn't continue this
way but
nobody thought that it was
it would be that what's being left
behind after moise's death
is a mystery of who was behind the
attack and a power vacuum that could see
a country go from crisis
to chaos mike armstrong global news
montreal
any power vacuum in haiti could further
complicate its handling of a recent
surge
in covet 19 cases haiti is just one of
five countries that has yet to begin
vaccination campaigns until recently
case numbers in the country remain
low although testing has been limited
but in may
infections and deaths increased
five-fold
a rise attributed to variants since the
start of the pandemic
haiti has recorded fewer than 20
thousand confirmed cases of coven 19
and less than 500 deaths nearly half of
those deaths have occurred
in the past three months and there is a
new warning tonight about the global
trajectory of the pandemic after
seven straight weeks of declining cases
the world health organization says
new infections worldwide are once again
creeping up
europe saw the sharpest increase in the
last week
with a 30 percent jump in new infections
now in canada the situation is more
encouraging case numbers are still
falling vaccinations are still climbing
and in ontario today a major milestone
that province reported zero new coven 19
deaths for the first time
since last october but despite the
progress
canada is still dealing with the threat
of highly transmissible
variants the world health organization
is urging every country
to avoid a premature rush to back to
normal
idea that everyone is protected and it's
kumbaya and everything goes back to
normal
i think right now is a very dangerous
assumption anywhere in the world
this virus is evolving this virus is
changing
and we need to be very very careful at
this moment so that the gains that have
been hard won
by the behaviors and action of our
population are sustained
one of the variants of interest flagged
by the who is the newly labeled
lambda variant or c37 there are concerns
it carries mutations that could
potentially make it
more resistant to neutralizing
antibodies
it has been detected in close to 30
countries including here in canada
our health reporter jamie morocco is
looking into what we know about
this new variant as masks come off and
life returns to normal canada's public
health agency confirms 11
cases of a new covet 19 variant what we
do know is that it does look highly
transmissible
c-37er lambda was first detected in peru
in late 2020
and now accounts for more than 80
percent of the country's cases
now spreading across south america
lambda is also responsible for one-third
of new infections in neighboring chile
we're in this period where we're we're
still
watching it and trying to understand the
world health organization says there is
nothing to indicate that lambda is more
deadly than other variants like delta
or alpha but experts who are
scrutinizing the effectiveness of
vaccines to protect against all these
new variants
do have concerns the immune response
seems to be
a little bit less than compared to the
wild type virus strains
two small studies out of the u.s which
have not been peer reviewed found
vaccine effectiveness against the lambda
strain can fluctuate
mrna vaccines such as pfizer and moderna
one study reveals
should offer some protection it has a
few
rather interesting mutations that could
it could make it actually fit you know
for again escaping vaccines partially
those mutations are why professor of
immunology omar khan says vaccination
needs to be a global priority the virus
can only replicate in people
and every replication event is an
opportunity for a mutation to happen
a double dose he says is our best shot
at disrupting kovid's evolution
jamie morocco global news toronto in
australia sydney's second coven 19
lockdown was extended today
over fears and outbreak of the delta
variant is now out of control
strict stay at home orders that were to
be lifted on friday are now
in place for another week 347 people in
new south wales have tested positive
since the first case at the delta
variant was detected in sydney
three weeks ago just nine percent of all
australian adults are fully vaccinated
and with just over two weeks to go until
the olympics japan is expected to
declare a state of emergency in tokyo
that would last through the duration of
the games coven 19 cases have jumped to
a two-month high
the government is also weighing whether
to ban spectators from attending
the assembly of first nations is
electing a new leader
seven candidates were in the running for
national chief after incumbent perry
bell guard announced he wasn't seeking
re-election
after seven years the first round of
voting has wrapped up as is the second
our chief political correspondent david
aiken joins us now david
is there a clear winner yet
no not yet far turning into quite a race
actually we they've just concluded the
second round and we're down to four
contenders contenders right now
and it's a tight race you need 60
percent of all ballots casts
to become the new national chief and
succeed perry belgaard and here's the
breakdown right now
a saskatchewan chief reginald bell rose
has
32 percent right behind roseanne
archibald
she's an ontario chief at 31 32-31
and then a little bit further back
another ontario chief alvin fiddler
he's at 22 once again you need 60
of the votes cast and of course as you
may know it's the chiefs of the country
who picked the national chiefs it's not
individual first nations peoples
who vote in this election just the
chiefs of the 632
first nations communities but not all
are participating
just 351 votes were cast in the second
ballot
and we'll see how the third round goes
here is the leader
reginald bell rose speaking earlier this
week to
the afn convention well when you look at
this role
it's not to divide
it's not to play games it's not to pit
region against another region
what i'm promoting is a common agenda
with the united
vision a common agenda with the united
vision
chiefs
now that's reginald bell rhodes of
saskatchewan his chief competitor
roseanne archibald from northwestern
ontario looking to become the first
woman
at to be national chief here's what she
had to say you can see
the tables are turning where canadians
are finally starting to learn what their
governments have done to our people and
our families
and we are gathering more allies and
with the support of our allies
we can make substantive changes for our
communities we must seize this moment
and take a quantum leap of change
and so the voters are voting right now
will know the results of the next round
somewhere around 10 o'clock eastern
we'll see if that produces a winner
pharah david aiken in ottawa thank you
david
elsa arrives in florida coming up the
impact on the sunshine state and where
the tropical storm is headed plus
looking after aging loved ones one
family's decision
not to use a care home
tropical storm elsa has made landfall in
florida the powerful system
is battering the state with strong winds
and lots of rain
causing chaos on the roads elsa is now
tracking north along the east coast
it's expected to reach the maritimes
this weekend as a
post-tropical storm north america has
set a new record
last month was the warmest june ever the
european union's climate monitoring
service says north america's average
surface temperatures for june
were 0.15 of a degree celsius higher
than the average for june 2012
the previous record holder europe was
also hit with high temperatures last
month recording its
second warmest june ever globally last
month was the fourth hottest june on
record
the eu agency says the findings further
illustrate the effects
of global warming
residents of canada's long-term care
homes have suffered
greatly during the pandemic accounting
for nearly two-thirds of
all kovid-19 deaths in many of these
facilities
promises to protect residents were
broken and months went by
where they couldn't see their family
today more restrictions are being eased
at ontario
facilities allowing residents to have
more visitors but
as mike draulie reports the pandemic has
changed how many of us approach the way
we care for our seniors
if there's one thing her family could
agree on last spring
it was that 81 year old audrey dinard
could no longer live alone in her house
on vancouver island
her daughter susan's home had too many
stairs and while the family considered a
retirement home
they decided amidst the pandemic to go
their own
way together selling audrey and susan's
homes
and moving into a new house family and
all
and i think you would have to have a
family that you're
comfortable with and you get along and
there's no arguing
that sort of thing for some reason we
just all click
as covet spread rapidly through so many
long-term care homes
more and more canadian families began
considering alternatives to assisted
living
a kind of generational rethink when the
ottawa hospital put this decision aid
online
to ensure families knew the risks of
taking a senior out of long-term care
it was used over 30 000 times i
certainly have heard stories in many
provinces across the country
where families have pulled their loved
ones out of care
and it could be in the dozens it could
be in the hundreds
i don't necessarily think it's in the
thousands what dr samir sinha says we do
know
is that the waitlist in ontario has
stayed relatively flat
which he says points to canadians
increasingly looking for alternatives
so a lot of people i think have
absolutely lost faith
in in our long-term care system and its
ability to keep people safe
especially during a pandemic seniors
advocates say the pandemic may have
finally spurred long overdue reforms
inside long-term care facilities and
resulted in something of a consumer
correction
there's a fair amount of research around
that shows that about 20 percent of the
people who
were in long-term care prior to covet
didn't need to be there
the dinards certainly fall in that
category but they also know they're
fortunate to be in good health
and financially secure for me it was
just a time to really reflect at the end
of the day
you know what do i want to accomplish in
my life and to be honest
like if i didn't take care of my mom you
know nothing else would have mattered
it hasn't necessarily been easy but the
decision was
microlight global news toronto
what happens when families want to pull
their loved ones out of long-term care
homes can they return without going to
the end of the wait lists
mike drollay explores that issue
less is more still ahead a new study
finds shorter work
weeks are better for business
working less may actually be more and
the key to success according to the
world's largest study out of iceland
a four-year study involving more than 2
000 public servants looked at the impact
of
a shorter work week and it found that
working full-time
but only four days a week provides just
as much pay
and productivity as ann gaviola explains
a community in canada
is putting it to the test zorra is a
rural township just east of london
ontario it's 14 municipal staffers part
of one of the country's largest trials
of the four-day work week
they work a compressed week longer hours
from either monday to thursday or
tuesday to friday
it works out to the same number of hours
and the same pay for those that have
small children it's one less day of day
care
in my case my father's elderly so that's
my day i take him to appointments
there are challenges scheduling meetings
when all participants are working
setting voicemail and out of office
reminders after a successful pilot the
second phase of the eight-month trial
kicked off this week and runs until
october staff and researchers at western
university will evaluate from there and
make recommendations for the future
i found within even the first couple of
weeks that my work-life balance was
improved and i was able to do a lot more
things with family and in my personal
life and come to work
recharged the township hopes to use it
as a recruitment tool keeping the
community competitive with other centers
that can offer more money
zora's project is modeled on a
pioneering trial of 60 public servants
in guysborough nova scotia
when news broke that we were trying this
four day work week pilot
i had so many classmates messaging me
and asking if
zoro was hiring or if there's any jobs
going to be coming available because
everyone was very interested
but labor experts say the four-day week
won't work for certain types of jobs
painstaking physical labor or tasks that
require intense concentration like
developing computer code
see reduced productivity with longer
shifts the pandemic has been a taste of
the impact of compressed staggered
schedules on a larger scale
unintended consequences some good some
bad well i mean look at traffic
right look at traffic i mean the
pandemic has shown us that
you get the cars off the road you can
get to where you're going pretty quickly
i've taken
calls from all across the country from
municipalities and private businesses
also looking for information on the four
day work week so it seems to be catching
on
and gaviola global news toronto
next the 22 year old canadian winning
hearts at wimbledon
and fighting the world's best for a
trophy
a canadian tennis player pulled off a
thrilling win at wimbledon
dennis shapovalov advanced to his first
ever
grand slam semi-final he beat russia's
karen hachenov in five sets
chapavalov's next match is against
number one in the
world novak djokovic this friday and it
certainly will not be easy
but as crystal gomezing reports the
underdog canadian
is ready for a fight 22 and
already a fan favorite at wimbledon
denis chapel vallov
the canadian from richmond hill
victorious
he's headed to his first grand slam
semi-final
but to get there it took extraordinary
resolve
pushing through a marathon thriller that
lasted nearly
three and a half hours if he wants to be
the first canadian
ever to win wimbledon he'll first have
to take down
a tennis giant novak djokovic
the defending champion and a legend on
grass
i think anything is possible and when
when you look at the scoreboard you know
for
first thing on whatever it is friday
it's going to be 0-0 you know so
that's it want proof anything is
possible
two rising canadian stars made it to
these quarter-finals
felix o'jay aliasim lost his match but
his performance at wimbledon
also establishes new career heights at
20.
i think the the thing that's most
surprising about dennis and felix is
actually their age because
players right now peak in their late 20s
and you know to think felix isn't going
to be 21 until august and dennis
just turned 22 like their best years are
actually ahead of them
the two are good friends and have risen
through the ranks together
in 2014 o'jay aliya sim won the junior
grand slam at the u.s
open shapovalov won the junior grand
slam at wimbledon
fast forward to the main event this week
and it's clear the future of canadian
men's tennis
is now there's going to be more kids
that not only enter the game
because of their success but also
believe in their game when they're 11 12
13 years of age on the men's side only
milos raonic
has ever made it to the wimbledon final
it's a tennis match and it could go
either way and i have full belief
in in me and my team right now shepa
vetloff has a chance to make history
every time he takes the court crystal
gomansing global news
london and that's global national for
this wednesday
i'm farah nasser there is more sports
history to be made tonight
as the montreal canadiens and tampa bay
lightning face off for game five of the
stanley cup finals
and here's hoping these hockey moves
will help the haves
canadian fungus dog pander is sending
good luck
through dance until tomorrow take care
of yourselves
and each other
[Music]
you